Marie-Pierre m'a fait découvrir les
valeurs du Mouvement
[Musique]
Démocrate bonjour je m'appelle Louise
Daniel j'ai 21 ans je suis secrétaire
général adjointe des Jeunes Démocrates
et présidente des jeunes démocrate en
[Musique]
Bretagne j'ai réalisé une licence de
droit public à l'université de Vann et
maintenant je suis à Paris Saclay je
fais un master de politique de
communication et d'affaires publiques et
puisque ce master est en alternance je
me spécialise dans les politiques
publiques agricoles depuis tout au tit
je m'intéresse à la politique et depuis
2 ans je me suis engagée au sein des
Jeunes Démocrates cet engagement il a
commencé grâce à Marie-Pierre vdren qui
est député européenne et élu en Bretagne
Marie-Pierre m'a fait découvrir les
valeurs du Mouvement Démocrate que sont
l'écologie l'humanisme le projet
européen entre autres et c'est cet
ensemble de valeurs qui m'a fait adhérer
au
[Musique]
modem